Thank you guys
for coming.
I'm super excited.
Carla is a good friend and she's in my head a lot,
which just probably a little dangerous.
But,
um,
she was here last year.
She had her first book.
This is her second book.
I haven't read it yet.
I know it's gonna be amazing.
Um,
one of my experiences that I can share.
My daughter just turned two and on her second birthday,
literally she woke up from her nap and screamed for 15 minutes.
I timed it.
Um,
no reason.
She woke up crying.
She,
whatever was going on,
the first thing that popped into my head was Carla's voice from the first book
telling me that I need to react in a way that's going to help her.
And it was a total mindfulness thing where I just sat there and held her and was
calm and as peaceful as possible.
And we did it for it to all pass.
And we keep doing that as she wakes up from nap screaming.
But the thing that I find is that she walks away from that in a much calmer
state than had I gotten super upset.
Super worried,
reacted with her reaction.
So that's Carla in my head.
Um,
she has this awesome new book.
It's called ready,
set,
breathe.
And it's practicing mindfulness with your children for fear of meltdowns and
more peaceful family.
And I'm so excited to read it.
So without further ado,
Kyla,
yeah,
fabulous.
Thank you all so much for coming today.
This is as Tash mentioned,
my second time speaking here at Google and I had a fabulous time last year,
so I'm thrilled to be back and I want to say thank you,
especially to toss Ross who helped set this all up and she's been super
supportive and great.
Um,
so what we're gonna do today is I'm going to do some reading from the book so
you can get a sense of what the book is like.
I'm going to do a little bit of talking about the book,
about mindfulness with our kids,
and then we'll have some time for questions and answers.
So I hope that sounds good.
All right,
we're going to dive right in at the very beginning and the introduction.
Will you please just calm down and take a breath?
I snapped at my five year old daughter the other morning.
We had both gotten up on the wrong side of the bed and things had gone downhill
from there.
She was circling me in the kitchen,
whining and crying because we had run out of her favorite cereal and I had
denied her request to take a tiny and very beloved toy to preschool.
Her four year old sister who was supposed to be sitting at the table eating her
breakfast,
kept getting down to grab a toy or finish a drawing she was working on and I had
to keep reminding her to get back in her seat and finish eating.
Meanwhile,
I was stressed about everything I needed to do that morning,
make lunches,
get dressed,
finished packing my work bags and hustle everyone out the door on time.
In the back of my mind,
I was feeling guilty about leaving that afternoon for a three day work trip,
even though I knew the girls would be fine at home with their dad who sitting
right over there.
Hi Josh.
Um,
I also knew that my impending absence was part of why my daughter was having
such a hard morning and I couldn't help but feel bad about it.
Not unlike my little girl.
I was tired and overwhelmed and barking at her to breathe was the closest I
could get to my mindfulness practice in that moment,
which is to say not very close at all.
Not surprisingly,
she responded in kind.
They don't want to breathe mommy.
The ridiculousness,
ridiculousness of her statement may have been lost on her,
but it snapped me out of my own irritability just long enough to give me a
little perspective.
I put down the peanut butter knife,
put my hands flat on the counter and took a few deep breaths.
When I felt myself calmed down a little bit,
I picked up my daughter,
sat her down on my lap and kept breathing.
Eventually her heaving chest calm down and her breathing became more slow and
steady.
After a few minutes,
she asked me what I was doing.
I'm just breathing.
That's all.
Oh,
she replied with a smile.
Me Too.
And so we sat for a few minutes and just breathe together.
While I know that she actually was breathing,
I don't know if she was aware of her breath in the same way I was.
I had been purposely paying attention to the air,
moving in and out of my nose and each time a stressful thought entered my mind
about everything I had to get done or how I was going to get her sister eat her
breakfast.
I let the thought go and came back to my breath.
For All I know,
my daughter could have been thinking about baby dolls or Unicorns or ice cream
sandwiches,
anything but her breathing.
The truth is it doesn't really matter.
By the time I went back into the kitchen,
we were both feeling a lot calmer,
more connected and present with each other and ourselves.
It's not that anything had really changed.
My daughter still wasn't getting her favorite breakfast or bringing her toy to
school and I still had a million things to do.
The difference was that once we had calmed down,
rather than freaking out in our own minds are subsequently all over each other.
We were both able to deal with these challenges a little more effectively.
The moment,
etc. Morning on a better path was the moment when I put down the knife.
Oh yeah.
Put down the knife,
mindful parenting pro tip,
put down the knife and took a few deep breaths.
When I did that,
I was intentionally trying to get myself into a more mindful mindset,
which is simply about paying attention to whatever's happening right here and
right now without judging it or wishing it was different.
I had spent most of the morning doing one thing with my body,
showering,
getting dressed or making breakfast,
and another thing with my mind,
generally stressing,
worrying,
and feeling guilty.
This split attention characterizes the way most of us move through our daily
lives most of the time,
often without even noticing it.
Multitasking often feels a void,
unavoidable in modern life,
and it can at times help us be a bit more efficient.
More often than not,
however,
it leads to increased stress,
mistakes and errors and snappy responses to our children.
When I was in the kitchen making sandwiches,
I was so wrapped up in my own unhelpful thoughts that I wasn't really paying
attention to what was going on with my daughter,
which is how we got caught up in a power struggle over toys and cereal.
But after taking the time to notice what was really happening,
I was able to respond to it in a much more skillful and effective way by giving
my daughter the attention she had been asking for all along.
The deep breaths I took were an important step in helping me get out of my own
head and back into the present.
And that's what mindful parenting is all about.
Making a choice to focus our attention on the present moment with kindness and
curiosity so we can make a thoughtful choice about how to proceed rather than
reacting out of frustration.
So I chose this passage from the book for a few reasons.
Number One,
as you noticed that moment of mindfulness with my daughter started with me,
right?
I was in a pretty not helpful headspace and I kind of had to turn it around so
that I could then be present with my daughter.
And in the process I was teaching her something.
The second important point from that is that mindful parents are not mindful all
the time.
There is this assumption when somebody says,
I practice mindful parenting,
especially if they say it in a noxious voice like that,
that it sounds like you assume they sort of walked through their parenting life,
blissed out in zenned out and totally present and calm no matter what happens.
And I don't know,
I've never met anyone like that and I'm certainly not like that.
And um,
what mindful parenting means or practicing mindfulness means is that we have a
set of school skills and tools and a specific insight about our own experience
that we can use when we get off track.
And I get off track many times a day.
And all it means is that when I can finally notice that my mind is a million
miles away,
that I'm not paying attention,
that I'm wrapped up in my own thoughts and worries.
I now have this understanding that I don't have to take the bait of my own brain
as it were.
I can make a choice to come back to the present moment.
And often that means just taking a few breaths until I can figure out what I
actually need to focus on.
Uh,
the next reason I read that passage is because when we are teaching mindfulness
to our kids,
it works best if we do it with them,
especially initially,
but in an ongoing way.
And I think we all have this little fantasy that we can kind of hand our kid a
snowglobe or glitter won and say,
here,
go look at this and breathe and come back when you're calm.
And yes,
I wish that too,
but it just doesn't work that way.
Most of the time we need to sit with our kid and do the practice with them and
we're both going to benefit and eventually they'll integrate it and be able to
do it on their own.
And the last,
uh,
reason I read that is it's really important to be transparent with our kids
about what we're doing.
And so in that moment my daughter said,
what are you doing?
And I said,
I'm breathing.
And I specifically said that to her because I wanted her to know exactly what I
was doing.
I didn't say I'm trying to calm down because that doesn't help her like that,
doesn't tell her,
give her any information about what we do to try to calm down.
So I was very concrete.
I'm breathing and being transparent about our own mindfulness practice is
actually harder than it sounds because it's such an internal experience.
It's all about our minds and how we're perceiving the world and what we're
choosing to focus on and finding a way to say to your kids,
I'm having a really hard time.
I'm about to lose it all over you.
I'm going to go in the other room and breathe.
It's weird.
It's a weird thing to do because you have to have the presence of mind to notice
what's going on.
You have to be able to remember to tell it to your kids and then you have to
actually go do it,
which is the hard part because we say all these things we're going to do and
then we don't do them.
So that's the tricky part.
Uh,
but I found that,
you know,
for a long time when I was about to lose it or when I had just lost it,
when I'd yelled at my kids,
I would go on the kitchen and put my hands on the counter and start breathing,
and then I'd come back and I'd be a little calmer.
And my daughter's had no idea what I was doing in there for all they knew I was
sticking my head in the refrigerator.
So I had to make a point of starting to say to them,
I'm going in the kitchen to breathe so I can calm down.
And now they'll say,
oh,
mommy must be upset.
She's going,
she's breathing,
Mommy's breathing.
Yes,
I'm breathing.
So those are some important points.
Um,
now modeling and transparency are just two of the ways we can teach mindfulness
to our children.
And I would argue they're two of the most important ways.
Um,
but some other ways are sharing an activity with your kids such as reading a
children's book.
There's some really great ones out there.
Um,
my favorite current picture book,
which is probably good up through second or third grade,
is called Charlotte in the quiet place by [inaudible].
And it's a lovely story about this little girl named Charlotte who can't,
she lives in a busy city.
She can't find any quiet.
And she goes out for a walk with their dog.
The dog runs away,
she chases him,
and then they're both kind of panting because they'd been running.
And in that she finds her breath and find a quiet place.
Um,
but you can read a children's book to your kids.
There are some great apps for kids.
Um,
just to be clear,
screen time is not mindfulness practice,
right?
Because even though our kids look like they're being calm and focusing their
spacing out,
it's not mindfulness.
So that's not to say screen time is bad.
It's just to say,
don't think your kids are metaphor.
Meditating in front of Chi you.
Cause they're not.
Um,
and then you can also teach your kids specific skills and tools like breathing
activities,
noticing activities.
And I'm going to talk about some of those today,
but before we go on,
I want to take a minute to define mindfulness because this is a word that's all
over the place these days.
And I think many of us have misconceptions about what it is and what it isn't.
So the traditional sort of western definition of mindfulness,
which was first put forth by Jon Kabat Zinn,
who worked out at umass Worcester for a long time and he started mindfulness
based stress reduction.
Uh,
his traditional definition is paying attention to the present moment,
um,
in a nonjudgmental way.
Now,
I don't know about you,
but those are pretty big words for kids.
And I personally don't like it when somebody tells me to pay attention.
I don't think my kids respond particularly well.
And furthermore,
how many times,
how many of you have ever had someone tell you or defined for you or tell you
how to pay attention?
Okay.
Anybody I don't like.
So what did you hear?
What,
what did somebody tell you?
Nope.
Okay.
So for everybody out there,
what he said was,
uh,
he was told to focus on what they were saying and listen to the way they wanted
him to listen and it didn't feel very helpful.
I agree.
That doesn't sound very fun.
So the,
the definition I like for kids,
which I also borrowed components from Amy Saltzman,
who's a physician out in the bay area who also teaches mindfulness,
is noticing the present moment with kindness and curiosity.
So we can choose our next behavior that choosing the next behavior.
That's like the pot of gold at the parent,
at the end of the parenting rainbow,
right?
We all want kids who can take a moment and say,
I'm actually going to choose to use my words instead of dropping to the floor
and screaming like a crazy person.
So that's what we're going for with our kids and with ourselves is this sense
that we have some choice in what we're going to do instead of just reacting.
So let's,
let's break down this definition a little bit.
So the first part isn't noticing.
Kids know how to notice,
right?
My daughter can notice a baby at all from like a mile away.
She's got an insane radar for it.
Um,
little boys often can notice trucks and tractors and I know gender split,
Blah Blah Blah.
But what I've seen,
this is like how it seems to break down.
So noticing is super important because so much happens in our life that we just
don't even see it.
I mean,
we can walk through our,
I mean I've driven the same way to school every day and I had no idea that the
giant Santa was up on the corner until my daughters were like,
whoa,
they're Santa there.
And I think he'd been there for a week.
This thing is like 10 feet tall.
It's enormous.
I was so wrapped up in my own mind,
I missed it.
Right?
So,
so much of our life happens without noticing it.
And if we aren't noticing,
if we aren't paying attention to use that phrase,
it'll go right past us.
And so how do we notice things while we can notice them with our eyes,
we can notice them with our ears.
With,
I mean all of our senses when we touch something,
when we taste it,
when we smell it,
but the art of noticing is about,
or paying attention is about choosing to bring our attention,
whatever part of our body we're doing that with and focus it on something,
right to like notice it,
to pay attention to it.
And then when our mind wanders,
we bring it back.
And that's the part that I think we lose in this definition is that everybody
assumes that when you're paying attention,
you are paying 100% attention in your mind.
Never strays.
Well,
I don't know how many of your minds can do that,
but mine certainly can't.
And so the trick to noticing and paying attention is to be okay when your mind
wanders and then say,
oh,
my mind just wandered.
I'm going to bring it back to what we're talking about.
So that's the first part.
The next part is the present moment.
Now,
the vast majority of us spend the vast majority of our time in the past or in
the future.
We're worried about something that may or may not happen.
We're planning for events where sort of fantasizing about how a conversation may
go or were in the past kind of regretting wishing things had been different or
feeling nostalgic for something that's already gone.
Um,
this is a very useful skill to have.
In fact,
you know,
the caveman whenever millions of years ago who could remember that when uncle
Joe went into that cave and got eaten by a saber tooth tiger and can plan in the
future to not get eaten by the saber tooth tiger is the one who's more likely to
have kids and you know,
pass along his genes.
So this brain that can do this is a very useful thing.
And you know,
and now as parents,
when we can remember the Anna Filactic shock that our kid had when she ate a
peanut and make a plan to send it peanut free cupcake to the birthday party,
not only are we avoiding an allergic reaction,
but potentially a major meltdown.
So this is a good thing.
The problem is our brains don't know when to turn it off,
right?
We're constantly doing it and there's a couple of problems with this.
One is we can't get accurate data on what's actually happening if we're not
paying attention to what's actually happening.
If we're too busy filtering the world around us through a lens of what's going
to happen next,
or oh gosh,
this is reminding me of this thing that happened all this years ago and now I'm
sort of thinking about that and I'm not really seeing and parenting man,
that gets us going,
right?
Because no matter what's going on with our kids,
we're always sort of balancing it between what's going to happen next and what
already happened.
So my daughter,
when she was having a hard time learning to ride a bike,
I was automatically like,
she's going to be 40 and she can't ride a bike.
And her husband's gonna wanna like take her on this bike trip to France and
she's not going to be able to go.
And all their friends are gonna go and it's gonna be like this awkward thing if
it's going to cause the marital 10 what?
That's insane.
But that's where my brain went.
And then of course I was worried about the past,
like,
Oh man,
last summer we didn't work on the bike riding and it's my fault.
If I had worked on the bike riding last summer,
we would totally be all over this and she'd be with all these other kids riding
their bike,
like a little gang of hello kitty sparkled gangsters or something.
Um,
but what I needed was to be with their right it be with her right there in that
moment,
holding the handlebar and walking with her.
That's where we can make a difference,
right?
The president is where the action is.
So it's where we can get the best information on what's actually happening and
it's where we can actually take action.
That's why the present moment is so important.
Um,
let's talk about this kindness and curiosity,
but this is also the nonjudgmental thing.
So for most of us,
when we actually come to the present moment,
we immediately judge it.
Sometimes we judge it as pretty good and then we whip out our phones and want to
take a picture of it,
which immediately it takes us out of the present moment.
Cause then you're like,
Ooh,
I got a Facebook message.
A better check that one.
And all of a sudden you're like,
you know,
buried with some other person a million miles away on Facebook.
Um,
or we judge it is kind of boring and we don't like boring.
Human beings are terrible and boring.
So we really want that to be different or it's great.
And then we're like,
oh,
it's going to end.
This is awful or it's terrible.
And then we all,
we can think about his house and we can get out of it.
Most of us,
most of the time are not walking around going,
Huh,
these are pretty okay right now.
All right with this or most of the time we're not curious like what's going on.
So if we're in a like a terrible traffic situation,
it's like,
wow,
this is miserable.
I'm never going to get to work on time as opposed to,
Huh,
why is all this traffic here?
Which it sounds like a really ridiculous question,
but it gets you out of this crazy mind.
So when we can be in the present moment with his kind,
curious stance,
not only is it sort of a much more pleasant way to be,
but we're more likely to take more effective action.
So there's this whole field of study now called self compassion.
How many of you like have that word come into your lives on a daily basis?
Even a regular basis?
Well,
my husband,
but yeah.
Okay.
Um,
so what researchers have found is that when you take a compassionate response to
anything that's happening in your life,
especially difficult things,
you are much more likely to take the next.
Your next action is much more likely to be more effective.
So let me give you an example that um,
most women,
many men can relate to.
You decide you're going to go on a diet and two days later you find yourself
eating an Oreo.
Now what most people think after they eat the Oreo,
I suck.
I'm miserable.
This,
everybody else can dye it and I can't.
This is so hard.
It's never going to happen.
Forget it.
And then what happens?
You eat the whole sleeve,
it's gone,
right?
The Oreos are gone.
But if your responses,
Huh,
that was interesting,
why did I do that?
Dieting is really hard.
Everyone struggles with it.
It's okay,
I made a mistake.
You are much more likely to put those Oreos away.
And this is true for almost every behavior change.
So sometimes when we talk about self compassion,
it can sound a little touchy feely.
It's actually an incredibly effective way to approach our own experience and our
kids experience.
And then the last one is sort of choosing our next behavior,
right?
So we've got noticing the present moment with kindness and curiosity so we can
choose our next behavior.
This whole noticing the present moment,
kindness and curiosity bit.
That's all about creating enough space in our awareness so we can figure out
what's actually going on and then make the best and most skillful choice about
what to do next.
Because most of the time it's like something happens,
we get this input and then we immediately react,
boom.
And that reaction,
it could be from a place of worry,
it could be from a place of anxiety,
it could be from a place of remembering something that happened two weeks or 20
years ago.
And we don't even know that we're remembering it.
Right?
Our brains work that amazingly,
that all of a sudden we're triggered,
our kid spills the milk,
the cheerio's,
right?
And we're flipping out at our kid,
not because we actually care about the spilled milk or cheerio's,
but because when we were kids,
we got yelled at for spelling Milken Cheerio's and it triggers that automatic
reaction.
So we can,
we can slow down and say,
Huh,
that's interesting.
Sounds really cheesy when I say it,
but when you do it enough times in your brain,
you get used to it.
Then we can say,
okay,
my kids spilled the milk and Cheerio's what is the most effective way to respond
to this?
And then you figure it out.
So does that all make sense right now?
All right.
So if we start with this mindfulness definition,
let's take a minute to talk about why do we actually want this for our kids and
ourselves.
Like why we parents have enough on our plate to figure out,
right?
Why interject this new practice,
this new idea?
Well,
there has been a shocking amount of research on this with kids,
um,
primarily in schools and clinics where they're teaching it to children.
Uh,
and what they found is everything we want for our child,
right?
Growing awareness of our body,
of their bodies,
their thoughts and their emotions and an increased ability to verbalize it.
And how great would it be if every time our kids were having a hard time,
they came to us and said,
gee,
mom,
I'm having a hard time today.
I think my stomach hurts.
Can you please help me find a solution to this as opposed to like melting down
and flipping out in the car on the way to school.
Right.
So kids do that.
Um,
increased resilience and ability to soothe themselves,
to calm down and to regulate their emotions.
This is something most of us grown ups are still working on.
If we can start to help our kids do it,
that's amazing.
Increased empathy is stronger sense of other people's emotions.
Improve competence,
concentration and ability to focus better sleep.
That's a good one,
right?
Um,
increased confidence,
decreased anxiety,
like all of these things.
And it sounds like this panacea,
like this magic potion and it's not.
But if you think of all of these things,
so many of them happen.
So many of the challenges we face,
not being able to concentrate now struggling with big feelings,
not knowing how to manage them,
not sleeping well at night.
So many of those come from this awareness and this attention that's all over the
place.
It's like that pinball machine you guys have right here.
Uh,
the thoughts are like constantly bouncing around and that makes it hard to do
the things we want and need to do in life.
So the good news is that our children are already a little zen masters.
Now there's two ways to think about this.
One,
the role of a zen master is to constantly push your buttons.
So you have lots of opportunities to practice mindfulness and I'm sure that's
the one many of you can relate to,
right?
Um,
but I would argue that children are also capable of great mindfulness of moments
of intense awareness,
concentration and presence.
The problem is they always want to do it when we need them to put on their shoes
so they can get out the door.
Having said that,
I would like you to read you a section from the book about sort of encouraging
these mindful moments in our kids,
how we can sort of recognize and support when our kids are already being
mindful.
Inherently,
I'm sure you've witnessed your child having a mindful moment.
Perhaps it's when he is intent on building the tallest lego tower ever or
spending an elaborate fairy tale about fairies living in the bedside table,
elaborate tale or is focused on hearing every word and note have a favorite
song.
Maybe it's when he's in the zone on the soccer field about to score a goal.
While none of these may seem like particularly mindful moments,
they are when your child is focused on just one thing.
When he's fully engaged,
not judging himself or wishing something were different,
he is practicing mindfulness even though he's not sitting cross legged on the
floor with his eyes closed.
When your child is expressing interest in the world around him,
by mushing has banana between his fingers to see what it feels like or by
stopping to notice a flower growing through a crack in the pavement or by asking
questions about what happens when we die,
why we have to eat vegetables or the shape of the human body.
He's being mindfully curious around about the world,
around him.
And finally,
when your child is being aware of and concerned about someone else's feelings or
health or wellbeing,
when he brings a special toy to a crying sibling or makes a card for a friend's
birthday or visits the sick friend after school,
he's practicing mindful compassion.
These moments are important for several reasons.
Each time our children are concentrating,
being curious or creative or demonstrating compassion.
See what I did there.
Concentrating,
curious,
creative compassion.
All the cs help you remember.
They are learning to pay attention and notice what is happening within them and
around them.
They are learning to make connections,
think in new ways and respond skillfully to difficult,
challenging or boring situations.
They are practicing empathy and kindness towards themselves or others and they
are on their own inner experience for inspiration,
guidance,
and soothing rather than counting on someone else to do it for them.
The more often they do all of these things,
the more likely they will be able to do them in the future because even the
seemingly small behaviors are developing and strengthening habits and skills and
the neural connections in the relevant parts of their brains.
These are just a few of the reasons why it's important to practice mindfulness
with our children when they're calm,
happy,
and doing well.
The other reason is that those are the times when they're most likely to be
receptive to what we're trying to teach them.
The more they practice these skills when they are in a good space,
the more likely they'll be able to access and utilize them in difficult moments.
As one of my mindfulness teachers once put it,
you can't practice crisis meditation.
As our children get better practicing mindfulness in the calm,
an uneventful moments of daily life,
the more likely they'll you'll be able to access this skill.
They'll be able to access this skill when we really want them to,
when they're overcome with anger,
anxiety or sadness.
Actively teaching your children about the ideas and practices of mindfulness is
part of the process to be sure and will be covered more later chapters.
However,
you'll be most successful in your endeavors.
If you can notice when your child is already being his own little zen master and
support him in that process or at the very least not getting the way.
So two important points here.
One is that we need to find and create those times in our lives when our kids
can be mindful and we can stay out of their way.
Because so often we're nudging and nagging and let's go and let's go and we got
to do this next thing and you've got to clean up your room and it's time to do
your homework.
And we got to get ready for dinner that we don't give them that space.
And so I was guilty of that too.
This year we had our kids in swimming guitar and dance and they're in
kindergarten and first grade.
And somehow when I set this all up,
it seemed reasonable.
And now that I say it,
it seems totally ridiculous.
But what I realized is that they had no free time and they needed time to just
sit and be in play.
And I was seeing it in their behavior.
They were getting grumpy and irritable and basically we'd spend all day Saturday
managing tantrums because they were exhausted after the week.
So swimming and guitar out there doing dance on Sunday mornings because we need
some place to take them in the winter on the weekends and that's it.
And we come home from school and I'm like,
go play,
I'm making dinner.
And sometimes they need a little help getting into it,
but once they're into it,
it's their space to kind of be present and creative.
Um,
and they really need that.
Uh,
and this is a big challenge for us parents parenting in this cohort,
in this culture because it's like we have to prepare our kids for everything.
They have to be able to play an instrument and speak a language where they will
never work at Google.
And the thing about that is they also need the emotional skills to deal with
boredom and frustration because we can send them to every math camp.
But if they get frustrated when they get one problem wrong and they give up on
the test,
it doesn't matter how much they know,
and especially at the younger ages,
but it all ages.
We need to create this space for our kids.
Um,
the next thing I would say that's super important is the reason that many of us
come to mindfulness for ourselves and for our children is to deal with our own
personal challenges and our children's challenges.
Like,
Dear God,
I want this child to stop melting down in Panera.
I can't deal with this.
And so then what we do is we bust out our little trick when they're having a
hard time that doesn't work.
That's like you trying to teach me to code computer languages when I'm like
really sad about something or really angry,
it's not going to happen.
Like we can't integrate new information when we're in a bad space emotionally,
especially little ones.
But all of us,
their brains are just flooded with hormones when they're melting down,
they can't even hear the words coming out of your mouth,
much less learn something new from that you.
So we have to find ways to start integrating this into our daily lives when
they're calm and happy and feeling connected.
And if we do that often enough,
then they'll have it available when they really need it.
So the other day,
my five and a half year old was sitting on the couch like this
and I was like,
rose,
what are you doing?
And she's like,
I'm visibly upset,
Mommy.
I'm weaving.
And like,
this is not the breathing.
Again.
I think is really going to help her calm down.
But for a month now we've been practicing breathing and doing breathing.
And finally she was like trying to breathe in the middle of a meltdown.
And I was like,
that is a huge win right there even though she was actually hyperventilating.
But we'll get there.
Um,
so starting at when your kids are in a good space and working on this and as
you'll notice in the book,
it doesn't have to be a huge thing.
It's not like we're going to pull out the meditation cushions and light the
incense and bang the,
you know,
singing bowl and sit down and breathe.
Like if that's your style,
that's fantastic.
But if it's like,
hey,
let's sit down and play Legos and I'm going to work really hard not to nag you
about how to make that tower the most stable tower ever.
And I'm just gonna let you be.
Or if it's like,
you know,
my daughters and I will sit on the front porch and I'll say,
let's just listen for sounds.
I'll give you one minute and I want you to report back to me two sounds.
And the minute is actually like 25 seconds because that's what they can handle
right now.
But they get quiet and they listen for two sounds and then I'll say,
let's just sit together and breathe for 10 seconds.
Can we notice our breathing?
My seven year old can definitely do 10 seconds.
My five year old is like four seconds.
My brain is like two seconds.
So,
but you know,
practicing these things and finding ways to work them into your daily life.
If you have a religious or spiritual practice,
you can say your prayers together and recognize that as a mindfulness practice
and many of these these things,
when you read the book,
you'll be like,
oh,
I'm already doing that.
We play Jenga.
I didn't know that was a mindfulness practice.
The trick is deciding.
It is.
So making a point to pay attention and the notice when your attention has
wandered and then bring it back.
And so all of these things when we really make a point to insert them into our
day,
um,
are going to end up being quite useful.
Uh,
let's see.
So I want to give you a couple of tricks and tips before I leave.
Um,
my favorite mindfulness trick is that you can't be curious and angry at the same
time.
This is extremely cool and I never noticed it until someone told me recently.
But curiosity comes from our prefrontal Cortex,
which is right up here.
And it requires that this part of our brain that can plan and think and process
and manage emotions that this part is online and anger comes from back here,
right?
This is like the reptilian fight,
flight freak out,
freeze part of our brain that's like,
I can't even think.
And even though you just offered me a snack and ice cream,
I'm still screaming at you because I'm losing my mind.
So those can't function at the same time.
They just can't.
So when this part's turned on,
our kids can't think or do anything.
But if we can get this part to come online,
the back calms down a little bit.
So one of the tricks I'll do with my daughter when she's really losing it,
and I have to wait until she's calm enough to at least hear my voice,
um,
is I'll try to get our curious about the world around us.
So if we were in this room together and she was losing it,
I'd say,
Hey,
can you find a screen in this room?
Like make it really easy to start.
So I'm not going to say,
can you find somebody who's wearing brown boots?
That's too much.
And then can you find me like a chair?
And sometimes if she sold lots of,
like she couldn't find a chair in this room,
but make it really easy and see if he can get them curious.
Now if you know,
my older daughter will say to me,
don't,
don't do that trick on me.
I don't want that trick.
I want to be angry.
And I'm like,
okay.
Then you let her be angry and you're,
your job in that moment is to stay calm so she can get through the anger.
Um,
so that's a nifty trick also in life when you're getting like pissed off.
Like when I'm pissed off in traffic,
I tried to get curious about um,
tail lights,
tail lights come in,
a lot of different shapes and sizes.
It's amazing.
I had no idea.
And I'm like,
Ooh,
there's a round one.
So can you get curious about something?
It really helps you calm down.
Um,
and then I want to read you a little bit about something called a cool down
corner,
which is a very helpful,
uh,
space to set up for a kid.
And I also thought it'd be appropriate for Google because you guys have like a
million of them here and they're shaped like airplanes and jails and really
cool,
well not jails,
that's not the best example,
but so creating a calm down corner.
In addition to making a more mindful environment throughout your house,
which is something I talk about in the book,
you may want to consider creating a special calm down corner.
This can be a small room or even a corner of a room,
a small comfortable chair or an indoor child's tent.
The idea is to create a space that is conducive to a calm,
mindful experience and that specifically cues your child to get quiet and
focused.
It's a good idea to involve your child as much as possible in the design of the
space and in choosing what to put in it.
You want it to be decorated in a way that appeals to him or her,
keeps her interested and helps her get in.
Stay calm.
Here are a few ideas to keep in mind.
You can choose a common theme for the space,
but you don't have to.
I have one friend who named her kids space,
the cool down corner and filled it with books about Antarctica as well as a few
stuff.
Polar bears and penguins.
Another friend created a Seton space.
She and her son cut out some stars and planets to hang from the sky and included
a few favorite stuffed alien doll and a few different space.
Theme toys and books.
Choose a few toys that your child would like to have or activities she can do
completely unsupervised.
So like if Plato freaks you out,
don't put the Plato in there like put stuff that you can leave the kid alone
with.
You'll want to work with her to choose things that are age or developmentally
appropriate.
Don't put too much stuff in the calm down corner regardless of how cluttered the
rest of your house may be.
This is an area that should have just a few items.
Too much stuff will make it hard for your child to focus and choose what to do.
You want to include items and toys that are known and comforting to your little
one,
not items to challenge her to try new or different activities.
No need to spend much money you likely already have or can make anything you
want to include.
No screens,
tablets or electronic toys in the calm down corner with the exception of an MP
three or CD player loaded with guided meditations and you can get them on like
Ebay,
really cheap that don't have a screen on them like the old school iPod ones.
This is not a timeout spot and your child should not be forced into it.
It may be a spot she chooses instead of timeouts.
If you use timeouts in your house,
but it should always be a place she goes willingly.
You want your child to have positive associations with the calm down corner,
which won't feel easy if it feels like a jail cell to her.
The calm down corner is a sacred space where shouting,
nagging,
arguing,
discussing,
questioning,
and negotiating are not allowed.
This space isn't for figuring things out or rehashing problems.
It's just for being,
breathing and doing quiet soothing activities.
That's all.
Once you're there,
you're safe.
And that last pit is the hardest part for me because I want to like go after my
kid and be like,
wait,
we're not done talking about this.
Not the time to do that.
If you don't have the space in your house to do that,
you can also create like a calm down box or a little cloth bag and you can put,
um,
my kids love silly putty is always a good choice and it doesn't,
I mean it can sort of get mashed into a rug,
but not as bad as Plato.
Um,
like they sell little glitter ones that are nice things to look at,
a small notepad and some pens.
If your kid isn't a Rubik's cubes and that's not going to stress her out,
something like that.
Anything they can sort of manipulate with their bodies is really useful.
Um,
or that will,
I mean some kids really like strong sense so you can find a little sentence
pillow to put in there.
Whatever works for your kid and you really have to pay attention to your child
because everybody's got different things that work.
And then the last trick I really have is get your kids outside as much as
possible.
And I know we all hear this and when somebody tells me that,
and I'm going to stress moment,
I'm like,
I can't even deal.
And have you met Boston winter?
Like don't talk to me.
But it makes a huge difference.
There's not as much clutter about around it.
Kids can move their bodies more.
All of this helps us get into a more mindful space.
And so in the winter we bundle our kids up and we go outside and sometimes we
spend 10 minutes getting dressed in five minutes outside and that's okay.
But it's much more easy for kids to get into mindful space when they're outside.
So those are some ideas.
There's a lot more in the book.
And at the risk of sounding like a TV salesperson,
there are over a hundred activities in this book.
And,
um,
I interviewed 30 different parents for this because there are many,
many great books on the market about teaching mindfulness to children.
And I can recommend some to folks who are interested.
Most of them are based on the author's experiences in schools and clinics,
which is really useful and important.
But anyone who has ever tried to teach their own child anything knows it's
really different from how kids learn at school.
And there's all sorts of dynamics that happen at home and we also have lots of
opportunities at home that don't happen at school.
Um,
but I wanted this book to be representative of a lot of different families
experiences cause my family is quirky and we have our own preferences in a
certain way of doing things.
So I talked to 30 different parents about how they do this at home.
So there's a whole lot of activities and ideas in here and choose the ones that
work for you and make up your own.
And don't worry if some don't work for you.
It's not your Gig.
That's fine.
But that's the book.
That's the talk.
Hopefully we have some time for questions.
Oh,
here's somebody you mentioned a one
picture book to share with kids in the course of it.
I wonder if you had any suggestions for even moving older,
the 10 and 11 year old,
who one is old enough to recognize?
Wow,
I regularly screw things up when I get really stressed out.
And you know,
I say things that uh,
I don't want to say so little older than picture book that maybe not ready to
just take an adult self help book off the shelf and
plow.
This is a question I frequently get.
It talks and I've been looking for something and I haven't found anything I love
for that age.
There is,
and again,
I don't like pushing his screen time for this particular issue because it's not
really what we're going for.
But there's a website,
I think I could be wrong.
I think it's called [inaudible] dot com okay.
But if you look up like zen anxiety,
kids,
youtube,
it'll pop up.
And whether or not anxieties the issue,
I know that that's one of the things they addressed and they have some pretty
good animations that are helpful.
Great damage.
Yeah,
please.
Then hour does it not work?
Oh yeah.
So the question was does it not work for kids under three?
No,
we definitely works for kids under three.
I mean my publisher was like picking age range and I was like,
okay.
But I mean the reality is it's all about figuring out what works for your kids.
Like under three you can totally start doing these activities with your kids.
The ones that are going to be most effective is the ones you practice.
And then it sort of leaks out for lack of a better term to your children.
So when we can stay calm,
when our children wake up from the nap screaming,
um,
that's a great one.
When we can let our,
you know,
toddlers and little ones have the space and the time to just play and explore
the environment.
And we're not like getting in their space.
And I never thought this would be a thing I did until I had kids.
But then I'm like,
oh,
you're playing,
let's make your play better.
Like let me get in your space and help you make that better.
And we,
Josh and I stopped doing this when we read a quote by Jack Black,
the actor,
he said,
uh,
in USA Today,
never give a happy child ice cream.
And I was like,
oh,
that's right.
I'll say the ice cream for when,
you know,
maybe they're not so happy,
bribed them with ice cream.
No,
but um,
like just if they're,
if they're doing well,
we were alone and that's surprisingly hard to do when it's especially me.
I want to get like in it.
And then Josh was like ice cream and then I can like step away.
So,
um,
with the little ones and also food is a great time to let them sort of mindfully
be curious if you can tolerate it right.
Because then you end up with food all over the place and it's like,
I just gave you a bath and now you have hummus and your hair.
But if you can let them really explore food and kind of sit with it and mush it
around,
that's a great practice for little ones too.
Do you have any tips for parents in the moment when kids are freaking out with
the parents that are freaking out because of it?
Yes.
Tips were parents who are freaking out in the moment.
So that's what the first book is about.
It's called parenting in the present moment.
But briefly,
yes,
when you are freaking out,
my tips are,
see if you can breathe,
like pay attention to your breath.
And a lot of times people think breathing meditation is this like whole big
thing.
Like you have to breathe in for four and breathe out for seven and then stand on
your head and then like chant a mantra.
It's not just notice your breath however it is,
wherever it is.
Some people notice it in their nose,
some people notice it in their chest,
some people notice it in their belly.
Just notice and that'll like calm you down.
Um,
another one is like for some people putting their hands on a countertop that
works for me,
Connie,
to get grounded.
For some people just sitting down,
like feeling your body in contact with something firm can help you feel
grounded.
Um,
and then remembering a few things.
One is unless your child is endangering,
you don't have to react right away,
which it can be such a hard thing when they're screaming.
Like they can screen for a minute,
they can tolerate it,
especially if they know there that you're around and they're safe.
And if they ask you something and you don't know what to do,
like you don't have to have an answer,
right?
You can say,
I need some time to think about that.
Um,
and the other thing is that you can always start a mindfulness practice again
and again and again.
So there's a saying in the mindfulness world,
which is that it's really easy to be mindful.
It's really hard to remember to be mindful.
And so some of us will get to this place where it's like,
ah,
it's the end of the day and I forgot to do laundry.
And I forgot to be mindful.
I totally screwed that up.
And then we beat ourselves up because we want to be these calm parents and
instead we yelled at our kids.
So that moment when you notice that you're ramped up,
that you're a million miles away,
that you're yelling,
whatever it is.
That's what Sharon Salzberg,
who's a very well regarded and one of the leading meditation teachers in this
country.
She calls it the magic moment.
Any moment you notice and become aware,
I am losing it with my kid is the moment you can choose to make a different
choice.
And every once in a while I have enough awareness that I will actually stop
yelling at my kids made yell.
And it's surprisingly effective because they're expecting this rant and then all
of a sudden you just stop and they're like,
Whoa,
what happened?
And so whenever you can catch it,
you can always stop.
And we also have this thing with parenting that we have to be consistent,
right?
So once you've laid the law down,
like you cannot change your mind to ever,
it's actually not true.
Like we make mistakes.
We say the wrong thing,
we set a limit that's not the right one.
Or we don't set enough of a limit.
You can go back and say,
actually,
I changed my mind.
Right?
But that it's,
it's important that we've,
when it can't,
it comes from a mindful place as opposed to,
I'm going to set this limit,
but now you're being a jerk about it and I don't really want to fight with you
and I'm tired and I just want you to go to bed so I can watch my TV shows.
So I'm gonna change my mind.
Like that's not really so effective.
But when you can say,
Huh,
now that I'm calm,
I realized I didn't actually mean that.
That's a better way.
But check out the first book parenting in the present moment.
It's got some good tips.
And also last tip and then I see there's another question.
Start practicing this when your calm,
because just like we talked about with your kids,
you can't teach them a new skill when they're freaking out.
We can't teach ourselves a new scale when we're freaking out.
So if we expect ourselves to be able to start a mindfulness practice when our
kids are like really pushing our buttons,
it's not going to happen.
So either try meditation,
which is a great one.
Or if you're like,
I am not sitting on a cushion right now,
that's not happening lady.
Then the other thing you can do is pick one or two activities you know you do
every day and pay attention to them.
And when your mind wanders as it will after about two seconds come back.
So for me,
it's taking a shower.
I can get to the end of my shower,
my hair is wet,
I have no idea if I watched it.
Not a clue.
And so can you pick one or two things you enjoy doing?
Don't make it harder than it has to be drinking your coffee,
reading to your kids,
whatever it is,
and just pay attention.
So that's the,
those are things that'll help.
And the more you do that,
the more you bring gets better noticing,
the more likely you will be to notice.
Yeah,
please.
Um,
this book looks great and really looking forward to reading it.
Thanks.
One place that we found the good ideas tend to break down is,
um,
when we have multiple kids and I'm curious to know whether the book addresses it
or not.
I'm thinking of the calm down space in my house that would turn into the thunder
dome.
Yes.
Kid.
We could maybe do that,
but then especially if there's just one parent at home,
yeah.
You got to go make dinner.
Um,
and usually,
you know,
we,
we try good ideas and then it's either yelling or TV,
you know,
it was like,
yeah,
those become our two options.
So I'm just curious if you have,
you know,
when you're outnumbered.
Uh,
yeah.
Anything in the book or otherwise that,
okay.
How many kids do you have?
A three so far.
Yes.
So you are well out numbered if you know this is a huge problem.
So the calm down space,
you're right,
this is a great,
a big issue that comes up,
but you can still do it with a calm down space.
Even with multiple kids.
And like in my daughter's classrooms,
in every classroom at my daughter's school from k through eight,
they have a calm down space.
It's one space for like 24 kids.
So they have to take turns and my daughter will come home frustrated sometimes
that she didn't get her term.
That's fine.
So having a space in the house is a good idea.
But yes,
when all three kids are melting down,
um,
that's when you have to put down the knife and like,
which I'm making reference to my own experience.
I'm not implying you carry knives around,
although,
um,
and,
and go be with them.
And that's a moment.
So one of the words that comes up a lot in mindfulness world is acceptance.
I don't love that word because it's like we have to accept and just be okay that
our kids are going to like cry forever.
I like the word acknowledgement better.
You have to just acknowledge in that moment that everyone is melting down and
you have to make the best choice you can.
And sometimes the best choices,
TB,
like practicing mindfulness does not mean we do the number one best parenting
intervention at all times.
And in fact,
I would argue that's not helpful for your kids because then your kids learn that
all of their needs will be met in the most effective way at every moment,
which guess what is not how the world works.
So sometimes you yell,
sometimes you turn on the TV,
but when your kids are old enough that you can start to strategize.
Like can one of them go to their rooms if they need a break and by choice,
you know,
can you use the calm down corner?
Maybe a kid needs to plug in some headphones and listen to a guided meditation.
Maybe.
You know,
I mean it's,
it really involves a lot of creativity.
But you can do it with more than one kid.
You just can't expect to do it perfectly all the time.
And that's when the self compassion and kindness and curiosity is really
important because it's like,
oh well I just lost it.
And so can I be nice to myself and forgive myself?
Because when you,
most of us,
when we do an unskillful parenting intervention,
we tend to beat ourselves up about it.
I'm a terrible parent.
I can't believe I lost it.
Everybody else is doing it better.
Um,
and then we get stuck in that.
Our kids come in the room when we bite their heads off because we're in a bad
head space.
So when you can be like,
okay,
well that was a rough moment,
glad that's over and you know,
thank God for TV because it's really useful sometimes then you're much more
likely to do a better,
have a better intervention next time.
But it's tricky.
Multiple kids is tricky.
Um,
you can also do a little like group meditation things like I'll get my girls
together and we do practices together.
And again,
this comes back to starting it when everybody's in a good space because the more
you try to just start it,
when they're in a bad space,
you're setting everyone up for failure.
And then,
um,
you know,
maybe boarding school,
I don't know,
that could help.
And yet there was,
was there somebody over here who had a question?
It was a sibling arguing.
Okay.
So here's the thing about sibling arguing.
I am not an expert in sibling arguing and I did a lot of it when I was a kid and
my girls do it now.
Um,
Laura Markham has a book,
m a R K H,
a m about sibling rivalry that I've heard good stuff about.
Um,
but I think that remembering that it's normal,
like some amount of it is normal.
This is,
I mean,
I saw some statistic that kids get into it with their siblings like once every
seven seconds or something.
Um,
yikes.
Uh,
but that it's,
it's an important part of their socialization.
Like that's how they learn to figure things out.
And what I would say,
and this isn't necessarily a mindfulness bit,
is depending on how old they are and if everybody's safe,
can you just get out of the way and encourage them to figure it out?
And one of my friends would,
she'll do is she'll say,
either you guys figure it out or I take away the 20 to go to your room and you
give him a choice.
And,
but again,
different families have so much different stuff going on that the sibling stuff
is really tricky.
I find the other really good trick for sibling is just making sure everybody is
fed and well slept,
which is like a good life thing.
Our worst sibling fights or in the afternoon when they're tired and they're worn
out and then I just have to like work really hard to get him set up in some
activity that involves relatively little interaction because they can't handle
it.
Um,
other questions?
Thoughts?
Yeah,
Jesse.
So thinking about being mindful and yes and how I would do that in my life.
I worry that a,
that time pressure is the enemy of mine.
Mindfulness and that a lot of times to be intense moments all have a time
pressure aspect.
Like I need to get this done by this time or get over to this place and taking a
step back and slowing down feels very hard.
Yes,
I agree.
And I think we can all
relate to you and certainly you can move fast and be mindful.
There's no question,
like mindfulness does not require us to be slow,
but it's just easier.
Right?
And so what I would argue is that they're always going to be days and moments
when you just feel like you're moving at a hundred miles an hour.
I think the trick is to convince yourself that you don't actually have to move
at a hundred miles an hour and you'll be more effective if you don't.
And my best example is I'll get really stressed when we're trying to get out the
door in the morning.
And I'm like trying to make the lunches or whatever.
Although in all fairness,
Josh make lunches,
most mornings I have to give them that.
But when I'm trying to like get everything together and what inevitably happens
is I dropped the blueberries all over the floor,
or I like I've got everyone in the car and I realized that I'd forgotten
something and we have to go back.
And so when we can start to convince ourselves that when we can practice,
um,
a little bit of mindfulness that will actually make things go faster and more
smoothly.
And when I say a little bit,
I mean literally can you stop and stand and take three deep breaths and then ask
yourself,
what do I need to do now?
Or if you're staring down the barrel of an insane day with a ton of meetings and
all these projects,
can you stop and take some deep breaths?
And if you're a,
if you're a person who likes to write things down,
can you sort of make yourself a quick list and say like what are the things I
need to focus on?
Because when our brains get going,
it's that forward thinking.
We get so wrapped up in everything that has to happen in the future and all the
worries about what if I don't get this done that we end up just reacting like,
oh and now this thing popped in my brain so I'm going to do this.
And then this thing popped in my brain so I'm going to do this.
And that may not be the most skillful way to approach the day and maybe better
to take a few like,
and it can literally be five minutes,
which I would argue that since most of us aren't like the president of the
United States,
we actually have five minutes.
We can sit down and say like,
what are the things I need to do?
They,
what are the most effective,
you know,
ways to plan my day.
And then when stuff pops up,
we had this map in our mind of,
okay,
but this is what I was going to do today.
And is that thing that just popped up?
Is that worthy of intruding on this space and time?
And it's the same thing with parenting.
You know,
if I can go into the afternoon with a plan or it,
I'm going to give my girls a snack and then we're going to have some play time
and then I'm gonna make dinner and then something pops up,
I can sort of make this choice.
Is this the most skillful place to put my attention right now?
And sometimes it is,
sometimes we just have to react.
Especially in parenting,
like when your kid's about to fall down the stairs,
you got to drop whatever you're doing,
go grab them.
But more often than not,
I would argue we react when we don't need to.
So I think small amounts of time on a busy day can make you feel,
can make you actually be more effective during the day.
This book is on Amazon and local bookstores,
and then parenting in the present moment is my first book,
which is really meant more for parents who want to practice mindfulness.
And I just really appreciate y'all coming.
Thank you.
[inaudible].